hi there steve here steve kaufman uh
you'll notice that i have my new link a
t-shirt on uh if you want a link t-shirt
we may be able to arrange that
my son mark is responsible let me know
i want to talk about learning
right now three languages at the same
time several languages at the same time
how do we keep them
how do we not forget them or what do we
do when we do forget them
um
because i finished my three months of
turkish i went from zero
to
the level that you'll see in the next
video where i have an hour long i
actually
i used zoom and i saw recorded the whole
hour of my uh lesson with um
dilara
you don't have to watch it all you may
not want to watch any of it but it's
there if you want to look at it with all
the
problems
that i had
and of course i get a report back from
dilora which has
a number of the uh mistakes words that i
didn't pronounce i mean you'll see if
you know turkish that i
mispronounced words got the wrong tense
god you know was looking for words
and she then sends me a good
list of many of my mistakes so that i
can review and hopefully improve over
time
but it nevertheless represents what i've
done in three months of turkish starting
from scratch
and according to my link statistics
i know now 7
741 words in turkish
the way we count them at link every form
of the word is counted as a separate
word
i have created 21 000 links that has i
have deliberately saved 21 000 words
many of them are
there i know i half know them i don't
yet consider them known they're words
that i have come across
all right
i have learned 5 000 links that means i
saved these and eventually converted
them to known because i felt i now knew
them
i have listened to 117 hours over three
months
so that's almost 40 hours
a month so it's more than an hour a day
i have read 185 000 words
in turkish a lot of it is reading the
same material over and over again and
i've had 15 one hour lessons
online discussions with my tutor there's
no question that i am much better and
you'll see the last interview or lesson
i did with dilara far better than i was
earlier i still make a lot of mistakes i
search for words i think about what's
the correct form i can't remember i
mispronounce all these things because
learning a language is a matter of
getting used to the language and i'm not
yet used to it but the more things we
become comfortable with the more things
we see the more things we discover the
more things we're able to focus on
so that that and of course the bulk of
my learning has been connected to
the many stories
and because i believe you first have to
get the language pounded into you before
you can sort of make sense of the
grammar
now
i am on a an experiment here where i'm
going to do three months i've now
finished three months of turkish from
scratch
the next i'm going to go back to my
arabic for three months after that i do
my three months of persian and then i go
back to turkish all right that's the
plan
however
because my wife and i are going to
croatia and then to spain in the month
of september
i decided i would take a month off from
my middle eastern languages
and prepare myself a little bit for
croatian
so we have serbian many stories at
length so i have now started listening
to these serbian mini stories
all i want to achieve is some sense of
the language for when i'm there
situations where i might need it or just
to be able to read and understand what
people are saying i have limited goals
all right
um
but i i am so much more confident now
because we have the many stories
that i believe i can get to at least
a situation where i can actually have a
conversation after two weeks
in croatia time will tell maybe i'm a
bit uh optimistic
one further comment
you know i believe you have to first
pound the language into you the mini
store is an excellent way to do this i
i believe that i have a i had a better
conversation in
turkish after three months than i did in
czech after six months even though i had
had russian and therefore was familiar
with
the grammar and the structure of slavic
languages whereas turkish is completely
different from anything i've experienced
before and the reason is the mini
stories and the fact that link is faster
better more convenient
now so the idea is with the many stories
is it pounds the language into you
and gets you used to the language now
you're in a better position to observe
what's happening by say looking up
grammar rules or i happen to have bought
for croatian this asimil guide
the conversation which is very well done
and i'm going to get more of these
because once you have invested in the
mini stories in pounding the language
into you
of course that doesn't mean that you can
just turn the language on at any time
um i've had the experience i've said i
studied ukrainian for a long time
without many stories but listen to a lot
of material in ukrainian
but then spent two weeks working on the
um slovak mini stories in link when i
got to the
polyglot conference in bratislava i
couldn't speak ukrainian i could a week
later i was in levi speaking ukrainian
without a problem however well with with
problems but able to communicate but the
slovak effort had pushed the ukrainian
aside and i know today that uh if i were
to meet someone who speaks czech or
polish even though i put a lot of effort
into those languages i can't produce it
given a few hours i'd be able to produce
it
same even more so with greek and
romanian
but i know that in those languages i
have
pounded the language into me at one
stage i did
and so that's where i'm very curious to
see i think these little conversations
are very good because they have a lot of
the sort of basic conversational things
that you would need in a variety of
situations which all by themselves would
be there very difficult to remember
however
if they are
if they come after you have done this
massive listening and reading then
you're able to retain them i know i
tried to do this for vietnamese picked
up a little guide i couldn't do a thing
however i have the feeling now that
as i because i've done a number of
slavic languages and i've listened to
about 10 or 12 of the many stories in
croatian or serbian that this now is is
valuable and so i'm going to go and buy
this for greek and romanian and
czech and polish the languages that i'm
you know
feel so
you know
tongue tied in if i try to use them now
so that's just on that score
so uh the goal here is so i finished my
turkish now i'm going to do arabic
starting in 1st of october and i'm going
to try to be disciplined so that i go
three months
with um
you know one language and stay with that
language for that month then go to
another language
um
i'm hoping that
what's gonna happen is obviously i'm to
slip so i go back to arabic i will have
forgotten a lot already now i have
trouble expressing myself in arabic or
for that matter persian
you know when i was doing my persian i
could go into the stores here in
vancouver and chat people up in
persian have sort of limited discussions
uh now i can't do that
but i know that when i go back to the
language
it's kind of like
cross-country skiing you know first time
you plow through the trail if the snow
is deep it's hard work when i go back
over the same material again i'll be
coasting along and i believe that i
would quickly get back to where i was
maybe within a week in arabic
then the challenge is to plow forward
because i have a sense of the language
now
i can always review some of the grammar
rules but i need more words because i
want to listen to podcasts and political
discussions and things of that nature so
my goal with the arabic would be to move
my vocabulary level up the difficulty is
finding that good content that does that
and in arabic that's difficult because
the movies produced in in egypt are not
in standard arabic so
i i don't know how i'm going to do that
but the goal is that i will sort of go
back to the language arabic for three
months then after that persian spend a
week to get back to where i was and then
i have to plow forward to get to that
next level
and maybe
these little conversation guides can be
useful for me when i need to quickly
refresh for a particular situation of
course in standard arabic there's no
no place where people uh speak naturally
in that language
[Music]
this is part of my sort of interest in
the whole polyglot thing in schools that
teach one language
uh typically well not everywhere but in
japan they teach english and canadian
english language schools they teach
french and vice versa and i think we are
capable of learning more than one
language
whatever we invest in learning that
language stays with us
all right
uh even if we can't remember it
it's we have invested in that it's there
uh the mini stories are still there if i
want to use them to refresh
uh so that the fact that i can't produce
it immediately
um
doesn't bother me it's a fact of life
those languages that i know well
i can produce them but the languages
that i haven't achieved that level that
i haven't spoken enough it's very
difficult for me to
suddenly generate them right
but this is therefore an experiment so
can i over a period of let's say two
years or so
working
on three languages
separately
get them all to a level where i feel i
can comfortably speak in other words
close to a b2 level i don't know if that
can be done but that's the experiment
one of the things that i think is going
in my favor is
every time you're trying to learn
something
and you're staying with it there comes a
point where you have a sense of
frustration you have a sense that you
aren't learning anything
you're beating your head against the
brick wall
so if i go three months with one
language as much as i'm reluctant to
leave my turkish i'm actually very much
looking forward to getting back to
arabic so that this element of
anticipation and curiosity and novelty
it's not new because i was there before
but i'm going to it again
so
because our brains need repetition
obviously but there's a sort of
declining efficiency in the sort of
repetition staying with one thing trying
to learn the most frequent 1000 words of
whatever language after a while you're
not learning anything so that this
introducing the new language
and staying there for three months and
then going to another language and then
back to the first language introduces
novelty freshness curiosity and so i'm
wondering whether that will
have advantages of course the
disadvantage is that i'm going to slip
in each of these languages so that's
what i wanted to say about learning more
than one language
uh i will be at the polyglot conference
in
tokyo in tokyo in fukuoka
18th to 20th of october if we can plan
meetups in japan let me know i'll do a
separate video on that just to see if
people are interested in meeting up in
japan so a little bit of a longer video
and if you are interested you can have a
look at me struggling with with turkish
i didn't edit the video i just put it up
i just saved the whole hour and you can
have a look alright then
bye for now
you